ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States accompanied by Eldrick
Tiger Woods
[Applause]
thank you very much please Melania and I
are delighted to welcome you to the
White House on this beautiful spring
evening this is the Rose Garden for
those of you that don't know and we use
it seldom but this is one of the times
we're using a tiger
today is my privilege to award our
nation's highest civilian honor to one
of the greatest athletes in the history
of sports
Tiger Woods Tiger congratulations on
receiving the Presidential Medal of
Freedom we're thankful to be joined on
this occasion by our great vice
president Mike thank you very much
members of my cabinet some of our
nation's governors and many
distinguished members of the House and
the Senate thank you all for being here
we're also pleased to have as where this
is Tigers mother
Katina his daughter Sam and his son
Charlie his girlfriend Erica and his
caddy Joe LaCava was Joe LaCava stand up
Joe and Scott good job Wow good job Joe
for over five decades the Presidential
Medal of Freedom has been given to
individuals who have made outstanding
contributions to American life history
and culture this evening we are in the
presence of a true legend an
extraordinary athlete who has
transformed golf and achieved new levels
of dominance he's also a great person
he's a great guy Tiger introduced
countless new people to the sport of
golf from every background and from
every walk of life he inspired millions
of young Americans with his thrilling
wire-to-wire victories Tiger Woods is a
global symbol of American excellence
devotion and drive at just six months
old Tiger watched from his
hi chair as his dad very special guy
also well I got to know him a veteran of
the Vietnam War and Army Special Forces
said he was tough tiger wasn't here but
good I think she might be tougher
she might be tougher practiced in the
garage of his family home at 18 months
tiger was on the driving range and he
was looking good people were saying Wow
starting at age 15 he won three
successive US Junior Amateur titles and
at 18 he became the youngest ever winner
of the US Amateur Tournament at 20 he
capped off his amateur career with an
unrivaled third consecutive title so
that would be six in a row and I say
that's a record that can never be broken
that's an incredible stroke play match
play everything that will never be
broken and in 1996 he burst onto the
professional stage as rookie of the year
but it was in 1997 at Augusta National
Bobby Jones's temple to the sport of
golf that the game would forever change
for four straight days at the Masters
Tournament Tiger stunned the world with
his power Grace and strategic brilliance
he shaped perfect 350 yard drives down
Augustus rolling fairways when flag
hunting at tucked away pins with the
heart-stopping precision like nobody's
ever seen before
and he buried one clutch putt after
another on that Sunday we saw Tiger
crushed the field by a record margin of
12 strokes unheard of with the lowest
score in masters history 270 at 21 years
old he became the youngest Masters
champion of all time and the first
person of African American or Asian
heritage to win the story tournament or
any of golf's four majors as a New York
time
headline said the next day woods tears
up Augusta and tears down barriers
incredible achievement after clinching
the green jacket amazing after clinching
the green jacket Tiger marched straight
to his first coach is dead and embraced
the man who inspired his enduring love
of the game then Tiger turned to hug his
mom the steady presence throughout his
life that's true I've seen that I've
watched that and the person who told him
that red is his power color wow that was
a good move
in the years that followed Tiger
launched one of the single most dominant
runs in the history of sports he holds
the record for the lowest scoring
average in PGA Tour history sixty-eight
point seventeen and two thousand and
remember he only plays in the hardest
tournaments that's a pretty amazing
thing I wonder what would happen if you
played thirty-five a year let's try a
tiger come on that back is in good shape
he played a record 142 consecutive PGA
events without missing a cut that's
incredible he has a PGA Tour winning
percentage of 23% of the events he
played a figure that nearly defies
comprehension nothing like it at the
punishing 2000 US Open at Pebble Beach
the entire field shot over par but Tiger
finished 12-under the first time in US
Open history anyone beat par by double
digits he led the field by 15 strokes
setting the record for the largest
margin of victory in the 150 year
history of a major golf tournament that
was the most amazing day of golf I've
ever seen Tigers cumulative stroke total
was 29 better than the field average a
month later at the British Open at st.
Andrews the home of golf
Tiger finished 19-under par
and eight strokes ahead of the field he
then took the 2001 masters becoming the
only player in the modern era to win all
four major championships in a one-year
period a feat known now as the tiger
slam Tigers determination and work ethic
drove golf to new heights of athletic
competition and popularity the age of
Tiger gave us moments that will live
forever and sporting law such as his
unbelievable chip in on the 16th hole at
the Masters
the shot rolled perfectly along the
slope of the green and hung on the edge
of the cup for a breathtaking three
seconds before finally dropping in we've
seen that shot many many times in the
midst of the success Tiger suffered
severe injury in 2008 he entered the US
Open with two leg fractures and a torn
ACL on the third day at Torrey Pines he
was 1 over par after the 12th hole and
it really looked like he had no chance
then came some of the most riveting
seams in golf history he goes the 13th
do you remember that Tiger I thought so
he's got a great memory this guy and he
remembers the good stuff which is really
important not the bad we don't want to
remember we just what you did there was
amazing because he chipped in for birdie
on the 17th and then eagled the 18th
hole all very vivid memories for all of
us in the final round on the 72nd hole
his ball was buried in very thick rough
101 yards from the pin and he had to get
it up and down to keep his US Open hopes
alive after hitting a 60-degree wedge to
within 15 feet Tiger will the putt in to
force a playoff that was a great player
with Rocco he fought through the pain
and won the dramatic 19 hole playoff on
unfortunately two days later Tiger
announced that he would be unable to
compete the rest of the season due to
his injuries in the years that followed
Tiger endured knee surgery and four
excruciating back surgeries I know that
you remember - that's not good
what it ended up good including a spinal
fusion in 2017 he fell from number one
in the world rankings to one thousand
one hundred and ninety-ninth I don't
believe that even if he had one leg I
don't believe that there's got to be the
best bet anybody ever made
Tigers injuries were so profound that
for two years he could barely swing a
club as Tiger said there was a point in
time I didn't know if I'd ever do this
again
if he'd ever play again but Tiger fought
through the terrible pain and he fought
all the way back to the summit of God
last year we saw a sign of what was to
come when he won the Tour Championship
people forget that but he won the Tour
Championship last year then just weeks
ago the world turned in to the 2019
masters and that was something special
what happened next was one of the most
incredible comebacks that golf or any
sport has ever seen when Saturday tiger
shot six birdies for a score of 67
sending him into the final round tied
for second place and just two strokes
behind the leader and they were looking
they were watching they were saying oh
no here we go again in gusting winds on
Sunday still behind by two strokes on
the 12th Tiger called upon his wisdom
and experience to play for par while
other players shot and unfortunately
they found the water there was a lot of
water they found he birdied the par 5 on
the 15th to take the lead for the first
time in the 2019 masters then on the 16
he shaped a perfect draw and the patrons
roared like they can only do frankly at
Augusta as the ball rolled to within
feet of the hole Tiger was back on top
and won his first major in 11 years and
that was some major with record-setting
television I don't know if you know
about that Tiger record-setting
ratings just as he did after sinking his
final putt on the 18th Hall all the way
back in 1997 he went straight to his
loved ones and embraced his kids who
were too young to remember the last time
he won a major
as of today Tiger is 81 PGA Tour
victories one behind the all-time record
gonna catch that soon he's won the
second most major championships he holds
the record for most weeks at number one
in the world more than twice as long as
anyone else that's an amazing number in
addition to his incredible playing
career Tiger is a successful
entrepreneur to put it mildly and
devoted philanthropist that's how I
originally met Tiger his TGR Foundation
supports junior golf programs around the
country his learning lab has helped over
165 thousand students pursue their
dreams in STEM fields Tiger we are
inspired by everything you've become an
attained the job you've done is
incredible your spectacular achievements
on the golf course your triumphs over
physical adversity and your relentless
will to win win win these qualities
embody the American spirit of pushing
boundaries defying limits and always
striving for greatness that's what he
does congratulations again on your
amazing comeback and your amazing life
and for giving sports fans everywhere a
lifetime of memories we can't wait to
see what's next
it's going to be good we know that it's
going to be good because there are no
winners like you and now I'd like to ask
the military aide to come forward and
read the citation for Eldrick Tiger
Woods Presidential Medal of Freedom
thank you
Eldrick Tiger Woods is one of the
greatest golfers of all time he is
second all-time in both professional
victories with 81 and major
championships with 15 including five
masters three US Opens three Open
Championships and four PGA Championships
with a record-setting performance in
1997 he became the youngest person and
first african-american to win the
Masters and in 2019 he became the
tournament's second oldest champion off
the course Tiger established the TGR
Foundation which has empowered students
to classroom and career success for more
than 20 years the United States is now
proud to honor Tiger Woods
whose tenacity willpower and unyielding
Drive inspire us all
[Applause]
[Applause]
Thank You mr. president
mr. Strom
[Applause]
thank you
I just want to say this has been an
unbelievable experience and to have the
support that I've had for all these
years and everyone here has seen and
been with me for some of you for my
entire life and in some of you for more
than half my life you've seen the good
in the bad the highs and the lows and I
would not be in this position without
all of your help in 97 yes I won the
Masters and I was there too I end up
hugging my dad and my mom my dad's no
longer you hear about my mom's here I
love you mom
thank you Sam and Charlie for all your
love and support guys so much thank you
I mean everyone has meant so much to me
in my life and I've battled I've tried
to I tried to hang in there and I've
tried to come back and and play by the
great game of golf again I've been lucky
enough to have had the opportunity to do
it again and found a game that has
allowed me to do this and the amazing
masters experience that I just had a few
weeks ago certainly it's the highlight
of what of what I've accomplished so far
in my life on the golf course to have
had that that type of experience and the
bill to come out on top and when Joey
thank you all the great reads to
I just want to say thank you again this
is an honor I know that I'm the fourth
golfer to have received this award the
late Arnold Palmer the great Jack
Nicklaus and Charlie Sifford who is I
always called him grandpa because he was
like the grandpa never had and I ended
up becoming so close with him that I end
up dating my son Charlie after him so to
have been chosen as the next golfer
after Charlie is truly remarkable so
thank you again and thank you mr.
president
[Applause]
[Applause]